Not long ago I went to see this movie called Fast, Cheap & Out of Control . Hadn't read any reviews, hadn't seen any ads for it. Didn't know anything about it, really. Except that it was by Errol Morris, a documentary filmmaker whose work I like. And that friends of mine enjoyed it. And it was great. It had funny moments and reflective moments and interesting characters. Totally satisfying, soulful film. And after the movie I'm walking through the theater lobby and I see the poster for the movie, which I somehow missed on my way in.
不久前我去看了部电影叫《快、贱、失控》。我没看任何评论，也没看过任何广告。真的对它一无所知。只知道它是埃罗尔·莫里斯（Errol Morris）拍的，我挺喜欢这位纪录片导演的作品。而且我的朋友们也都很喜欢。那电影真棒。里面有风趣的时刻，也有深思的时刻，还有有趣的人物。那是一部非常令人满足、富有灵魂的电影。电影结束后，我走过电影院大厅，看到了海报，我进场时不知怎么就错过了。
It was a bright, unnatural yellow. The main characters from the film are photographed with this fish eye lens so their heads are huge and their bodies are tiny. And there, in big print, the poster says these words, "The bizarre at its best." And I realized what was going on. Someone, somewhere thought that this film was wacky.
那是一种明亮、极不自然的黄色。电影里的主角是用鱼眼镜头拍摄的，所以他们的头显得很大，身体却很小。海报上用大字印着：“怪异的极致”。我立刻意识到发生了什么。有人，在某个地方，觉得这部电影很古怪。
Or they thought they could sell it as wacky. Which, if you see the film, is astounding. It's a great film but it's not wacky. There's a whole section of the film about death, a meditation on death. It's not wacky.
或者他们觉得能把它包装成古怪来卖。如果你看过这部电影，就会觉得这很惊人。这是一部好电影，但它并不古怪。片子里有一整段关于死亡的内容，是对死亡的冥想。它一点也不古怪。
Tom Bernard is one of the co-presidents of Sony Picture Classics. He saw what a great film Fast, Cheap & Out of Control was and bought the distribution rights from Errol Morris in a bathroom, at the Sundance film festival. It was, he says, the only quiet place to get anything done without competitors overhearing.
汤姆·伯纳德（Tom Bernard）是索尼经典影片公司的联席总裁之一。他在圣丹斯电影节的洗手间里看到了《快、贱、失控》是一部多么伟大的电影，并从埃罗尔·莫里斯手中买下了发行权。他说，那是唯一一个能办成事儿而不会被竞争对手偷听到的安静地方。
And he says they market the film as wacky for a simple reason. Wacky sells. Market a film as wacky and people come to see it.
他说他们把电影包装成“古怪”只有一个简单的原因：古怪好卖。把电影包装成古怪，人们就会来看。
Well, I mean, to me one of the ultimate wacky sells on a movie was Brazil .
嗯，我的意思是，对我来说，电影营销中最极致的“古怪卖点”就是《巴西》（Brazil）。
And what was the sell? I don't even remember that. What was the ad campaign?
那卖点是什么？我甚至都不记得了。当时的广告活动是什么样的？
It was just a bizarre campaign with sort of South American lettering style, you know?
那是个非常奇特的宣传活动，用的是那种类似南美风格的字体，你知道吧？
Right.
没错。
It had Brazil and a lot of wacky lines and colors. We had a movie, Crumb , which was a very, very moving film but to talk about R. Crumb, the guy's a wacky guy.
海报上有《巴西》几个字，还有很多古怪的线条和颜色。我们当时还有一部电影《克伦布》（Crumb），那是一部非常、非常感人的电影，但要说罗伯特·克伦布（R. Crumb）这个人，他确实是个怪人。
Even In the Company of Men was a very dark comedy and wacky to some extent. That's a movie we released and I think the campaign is a bit strange, a bit wacky.
甚至《男人行不行》（In the Company of Men）也是一部非常暗黑的喜剧，在某种程度上也很古怪。那是我们发行的一部电影，我觉得那个宣传活动也有点奇怪，有点古怪。
I don't know if you've seen any of these films, but they are-- every single one of them-- they are very dark films. These are bleak films, really. I suggested to Mr. Bernard that wacky seems to miss a lot of what these films are about. He said, no no no no. Look at the four characters in Fast, Cheap & Out of Control . Two of them are scientists. One's an expert on robots. One, the world's leading authority on naked mole rats. There's a lion tamer. There's a guy who carves trees and bushes into the shapes of animals.
我不知道你是否看过这些电影，但它们——每一部——都是非常暗黑的电影。它们真的是很阴郁的电影。我向伯纳德先生建议，用“古怪”来形容似乎错过了这些电影的核心。他说，不不不不。看看《快、贱、失控》里的那四个角色。其中两个是科学家。一个是机器人专家。一个是世界上研究裸鼹鼠的头号权威。还有一个驯狮人。还有个把树木和灌木修剪成动物形状的家伙。
And, said Mr. Bernard, that is, by most people's objective standards, actually kind of wacky.
伯纳德先生说，按照大多数人的客观标准，这确实算得上古怪。
The film is a very strange film. The people are very strange. I think, in word of mouth, people would talk about it and they'd say, look at these crazy guys, let's go see what they're up to.
这电影确实很奇怪。片子里的人也很奇怪。我想，在口碑相传中，人们会谈论它，他们会说，看看这些疯子，让我们去看看他们在搞什么名堂。
You know what I realized, as we talk, is that I guess I just don't think of people as wacky. I guess some people just think of people as wacky and some don't. I mean, when I think of all the people in this Errol Morris film, or I think of R. Crumb, I think of them as being people who are fundamentally very, very serious.
你知道吗，在交谈中我意识到，我想我只是不觉得这些人是“古怪的”。我想有些人会觉得人们很古怪，有些人则不会。我的意思是，当我想到埃罗尔·莫里斯电影里的那些人，或者想到罗伯特·克伦布时，我觉得他们本质上是非常、非常严肃的人。
Do you see them as crazy guys? Or eccentric guys? Or wacky guys?
你是把他们看作疯子？还是怪人？或者是古怪的人？
I think they're very eccentric and very wacky. And I think that if you know people in your world that you consider genius, and I think these guys are all geniuses at what they do, they sort of have a view that is so focused and so-- would people call Albert Einstein eccentric?
我觉得他们是非常古怪、非常离奇。而且我认为，如果你认识你那个圈子里被认为是天才的人——我认为这些人都是各自领域的天才——他们会有一种如此专注的视角，而且……人们会称阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦为怪人吗？
With all respect to Mr. Bernard, who, as far as I'm concerned is doing God's work, distributing these unusual, interesting, amazing films, with all respect I have a different point of view about this. Wacky to me seems to miss the point of everything interesting. Wacky eradicates empathy and thoughtfulness and feeling. Wacky is what people say when they're too polite to say freak. Wacky is what people say when they don't want to feel anything or think anything. Wacky is what people say when they don't know what else to say.
对伯纳德先生，我表示充分尊重，就我而言，他在做上帝的工作，发行这些不同寻常、有趣、惊人的电影，但我对他这一点有不同的看法。“古怪”这个词似乎让我忽略了所有真正有趣的东西。古怪抹杀了同理心、思考和情感。古怪是人们在太礼貌而不敢说“怪胎”时所用的词。古怪是人们不想感受任何东西或思考任何东西时所用的词。古怪是人们不知道该说什么时所用的词。
When you call somebody wacky you're ignoring who they are and painting a big smiley face on top of their real face. I didn't used to have an opinion about wackiness, one way or another. But after I saw Fast, Cheap & Out of Control I did. And that opinion is death to wacky. Death to wacky.
当你称呼某人为古怪时，你无视了他们真实的自我，并给他们真正的脸贴上了一个大大的笑脸。我以前对“古怪”没什么看法。但在我看了《快、贱、失控》之后，我有了看法。那就是：去他的古怪。去他的古怪。
And then we started putting this week's program together, this week's radio program. And everything I thought about wacky got thrown up in the air again.
然后我们开始筹划这一周的节目，这一周的广播节目。我脑子里关于古怪的一切想法又被抛到了九霄云外。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International it's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, 13 ways of looking at wacky. Act One, Negative. Writer David Sedaris faces a sheet of glass, a glass of milk, a floor of carpet tacks, and a photographer with big, big ideas.
好吧，来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天节目的话题是：看待古怪的13种方式。第一幕，底片。作家大卫·塞达里斯（David Sedaris）面对一张玻璃、一杯牛奶、满地的地毯钉，还有一位满脑子大想法的摄影师。
Act Two, The Good, the Bad, and the Wacky. We squint our eyes and try to distinguish good kitsch from bad kitsch, good wacky from bad wacky.
第二幕，好、坏与古怪。我们眯起眼睛，试着分辨什么是好的媚俗，什么是坏的媚俗，什么是好的古怪，什么是坏的古怪。
Act Three, The Politics of Wacky. A conversation with Michael Lewis about republicans, the press, and, of course, wackiness.
第三幕，古怪的政治学。与迈克尔·刘易斯（Michael Lewis）关于共和党人、新闻界，当然还有古怪的对话。
Acts Four through Ten, well, you'll see about those.
第四幕到第十幕，嗯，你们会看到的。
Act Eleven, Self-Proclaimed Wacky. We find someone who is not called wacky by marketers or promoters, she calls herself wacky.
第十一幕，自称古怪。我们找到了一个不是被营销人员或推销员称为古怪，而是自称古怪的人。
Act Twelve, Sidestepping Wackiness and Seriousness and Embracing Both.
第十二幕，避开古怪与严肃，拥抱两者。
Act Thirteen, Dr. Jeckyl and Mr. Wacky. That story from our own Sarah Vowel. Stay with us.
第十三幕，杰基尔医生与古怪先生。那个故事来自我们自己的莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。敬请收听。
Act one, "Negative." David Sedaris is a regular contributor here on This American Life . A Morning Edition commentator. Author of the books Naked and Barrel Fever . His stories are the sort of complicated mix of seriousness and funny that is easy to love but comes nowhere near, I have to say, nowhere near to wacky.
第一幕，“底片”。大卫·塞达里斯是我们《这就是美国生活》的常驻撰稿人。《早间新闻》的评论员。书籍《赤裸》和《酒桶热》的作者。他的故事是一种严肃与幽默的复杂结合，很容易让人喜爱，但我得说，这与古怪完全沾不上边。
What follows is a set of true stories plus a fictional story inspired by the true ones.
接下来是一系列真实故事，以及受真实故事启发而创作的虚构故事。
I wore my new tie to this afternoon's photo shoot. It was an extravagant purchase but I justified it thinking of all the money I would have spent on ties if I'd had a real job. I thought the magazine would want a picture of me standing with my book, so I packed a copy along with an extra shirt in case they had something against white. I arrived in the studio where the photographer said, "I'm not loving that tie much at all." He didn't care for the shirt, either and called out to his assistant, "Brian, hey Brian, do we still have that t-shirt from last week?"
今天下午拍照片时，我戴上了我的新领带。这是一笔奢侈的购买，但我通过想到如果我有一份正经工作，我本会花在领带上的所有钱来证明其合理性。我以为杂志会想要一张我带着书站着的照片，所以我打包了一本书，还有一件多余的衬衫，以防他们对白色有什么意见。我到达摄影棚，摄影师说：“我不怎么喜欢那条领带。”他也不喜欢那件衬衫，于是冲他的助手喊道：“布莱恩，嘿，布莱恩，我们还有上周那件T恤吗？”
The t-shirt was produced and I explained that I'm incapable of wearing anything with words on it, especially the words "Deliveries in Rear." "You are gay, aren't you?" the photographer asked. "It says right here in your press kit. Have I got the wrong person?" When it came to wearing that t-shirt he most definitely had the wrong person.
T恤拿来了，我解释说我无法穿任何带有文字的东西，尤其是印着“后门送货”字样的T恤。“你是同性恋，对吧？”摄影师问，“你的新闻资料里就是这么写的。我找错人了吗？”当提到穿那件T恤时，他绝对找错人了。
"Well, maybe you can turn it inside out," he said. "We won't be seeing much of it anyway since I'd like to get you crouched down on your hands and knees. Seeing as you're an author and all, I thought it might be fun if we shot you cleaning the bathroom floor, the black and white tiles are going to look great. So what do you say you change out of that shirt and we get started?"
“好吧，也许你可以把它反过来穿，”他说，“反正我们也看不见多少，因为我想让你蹲在地上，双手着地。既然你是作者，我想如果让你打扫浴室地板会很有趣，黑白瓷砖拍出来一定很棒。那么，你把那件衬衫换掉，我们开始吧？”
Then he called for his assistant to fill up a bucket of sudsy water, adding that the bubbles on top should be as fat as possible.
然后他叫助手去装一桶肥皂水，并补充说上面的泡沫要尽可能浓厚。
As a professional photographer, I have to say that my two greatest assets are my tenacity and my sense of humor. These are the tools I use on a daily basis because it's not just knowing how to operate a camera, it's also knowing how to get into a person's head, really camp out for a while. I'm not saying this right. So let me give you a little example.
作为一名职业摄影师，我得说我最大的资产是我的韧性和幽默感。这些是我每天使用的工具，因为这不仅是知道如何操作相机，也是知道如何钻进一个人的大脑，在那里真正地扎营一阵子。我说得不对。让我给你举个小例子。
After she won the Pulitzer Prize, everyone thought of Bobby Fingerton as some sort of a genius. Which is fine, but you could tell she'd really let it go to her head. It wasn't physically huge, not like a medicine ball, but you could see that she had this, um, this, uh, false idea of her own value or whatever. This is something a person like me can spot right off the bat. It's a gift I have. Just like my sense of humor and my tenacity.
鲍比·芬格顿（Bobby Fingerton）获得普利策奖后，每个人都认为她是某种天才。这很好，但你能看出她真的有些飘了。她的头并没有变大，不像个药球，但你能看出她有一种……呃，这种……对自己价值的虚假认识之类的。这是像我这样的人一眼就能看出来的。这是我的天赋。就像我的幽默感和韧性一样。
I'd seen her picture in a few of the weeklies and she was always, um, and she was always enthroned, you know what I mean? Just sitting there, propped up against the sofa cushions with a quill in her hands. Terrible pictures. They put you right to sleep but that's how it is when the photographer caves in to someone who's clinging to this very, very antique-y, destructive sense of dignity.
我在几家周刊上看过她的照片，她总是，嗯，她总是像坐王位一样，你明白我的意思吗？就坐在那儿，靠在沙发靠垫上，手里拿着羽毛笔。糟糕的照片。它们会让你直接睡着，但当摄影师向那些坚持这种非常、非常古旧、破坏性自尊的人屈服时，就是这样。
She clearly likes to play the grand duchess, but me? I'm looking for something wacky. Something nutty that will jump off the page saying, hey, is this person crazy or what? I mean, people like that. It's a kick.
她显然喜欢扮演大公爵夫人，但我呢？我在寻找一些古怪的东西。一些会让页面跳动起来的疯狂东西，说着：嘿，这家伙是不是疯了？我的意思是，人们喜欢那样。这很刺激。
It's easy when you're taking a picture of an actor because they'll just do anything for attention. I'm like, excuse me Mr. Cutahey but do you think you could maybe dip your head into this cauldron of steaming cocoa? And before I can tell him we need to wait a while and let it cool down, I look up and guy's already done it. I mean, there he is, his skin peeling off in sheets and he's there asking if he should do it again because that's the way actors are.
拍演员的照片很容易，因为他们为了博关注什么都愿意做。我会说，打扰一下，库塔赫先生（Mr. Cutahey），你觉得能把头伸进这锅热气腾腾的可可里吗？在我还没来得及告诉他我们需要等一会儿让它冷却之前，我抬头看时，这家伙已经做完了。我的意思是，他就在那儿，皮肤一层层剥落，他还问他是不是应该再做一次，因为演员就是这样。
They're not calling out the hounds or blubbering to their publicists, because they know how to cooperate and have a little fun.
他们不会大喊大叫或对公关人员哭诉，因为他们知道如何配合，并找点乐子。
Actors are no problem, whatsoever. But get yourself a politician or anyone owning a typewriter and you're in for a first class headache because these people have egos like you wouldn't believe. And you can quote me on that. Can we get another round here? Yeah, thank you. You're a lovely individual.
演员一点问题都没有。但如果你遇到一个政客或任何有打字机的人，那你就准备好迎接顶级头痛吧，因为这些人的自我膨胀你简直无法想象。你可以引用我的话。我们能再来一轮吗？是的，谢谢。你真是个可爱的人。
I told myself I'd try to be more aggressive and stand up to these photographers, but so far it isn't working. I'd like to ask if they've read or even seen my new book, but the question sounds snotty. I understand that they're busy people, I'd just like to know why they think I should be pictured drinking tea with a stuffed squirrel, or cradling an oversized can of fruit cocktail. I've never written about either of those things.
我告诉自己要试着更有进取心，站出来反抗这些摄影师，但目前还没奏效。我想问他们有没有读过甚至见过我的新书，但这个问题听起来太傲慢了。我理解他们是很忙的人，我只是想知道为什么他们觉得我应该被拍成和一只毛绒松鼠喝茶，或者抱着一个超大号的水果罐头。我从来没写过任何关于这些的东西。
My theory is that if you're good looking, they'll dress you up in embarrassingly trendy clothes but at least allow you stand upright. If you happen to be on the plain side they'll come up with a gimmick designed to make you look even worse than you already do. To complain is to insist against all reason that you're good looking, and that's even more embarrassing than going along with the humiliating little scenarios these people always seem so proud of.
我的理论是，如果你长得好看，他们会给你穿上令人尴尬的流行服装，但至少允许你站直。如果你长得比较普通，他们会想出一个旨在让你看起来比现在更糟的噱头。抱怨就是去坚持认为自己长得好看，违背所有常理，那比顺从这些让这些人看起来总是如此自豪的屈辱小剧本还要尴尬。
Today's photographer studied me for a few moments before asking if I'd brought another change of clothes. With the help of his assistant he then proceeded to clamp a large sheet of glass to a standing metal frame. Once the window was securely in place, he asked his assistant for a carton of milk. Then he looked at me, took a sip of the milk, and spat it out onto the glass.
今天的摄影师审视了我一会儿，然后问我有没有带换洗的衣服。在他的助手帮助下，他接着动手将一大块玻璃固定在一个直立的金属框架上。窗户安装好后，他向助手要了一盒牛奶。然后他看着我，喝了一口牛奶，把它喷在玻璃上。
"What I want you do," he said, "is to press your face again that milk stain. Really smash it up against there as hard as you can." When I hesitated he said, "Don't worry, the glass isn't going to fall. We've made sure of that."
“我想要你做的是，”他说，“把你的脸贴在那片牛奶污渍上。真的用力尽可能重地砸在上面。”当我犹豫时，他说，“别担心，玻璃不会掉下来的。我们确认过了。”
In his mind, this was my only concern. That the glass might break.
在他心里，这是我唯一的担忧。玻璃可能会碎。
So a servant leads me into the house and I walk into this paneled office where Bobby Fingerton raised her fat head and lowers those little half glasses people wear when they want to look smart or something. Now, I don't know what she's thinking, but I'm wondering, how can we turn this thing around and have a little fun with it? Because, hey, I'm a professional too. I deserve a little respect.
一个仆人把我带进屋子，我走进这间镶板办公室，鲍比·芬格顿抬起她肥硕的脑袋，放下了那些人们想让自己看起来聪明时戴的半框眼镜。现在，我不知道她在想什么，但我在想，我们怎么能扭转局面，找点乐子呢？因为，嘿，我也是个专业人士。我应得一点尊重。
But when I very playfully suggested it might be funny shoot her dressed as Aunt Jemima, I swear to God, the woman bit my head right off my shoulders. Not literally, but, you know, as a figure of speech. And I'm a smart person so when she refused the Aunt Jemima bit I figured she had some sort of a weight issue, which, OK, I'm as sensitive as the next guy. I can deal with that.
但当我非常俏皮地建议如果把她打扮成杰米玛阿姨（Aunt Jemima）会很有趣时，我发誓，那个女人直接把我头给咬下来了。不是字面意义上的，你知道，只是个比喻。我是个聪明人，所以当她拒绝杰米玛阿姨的角色时，我猜她有什么体重问题，这没关系，我和别人一样敏感。我能处理好。
So I said, all right, what if we shoot you as Prissy from Gone With the Wind or maybe, I don't know, Moms Mabley, she was thin.
所以我说，好吧，如果我们把你拍成《乱世佳人》里的普里西（Prissy）呢？或者也许，我不知道，妈妈·马布里（Moms Mabley），她很瘦。
I was trying to work with her. Maybe, you know, have some laughs but she automatically assumed this, this expression. I don't know what else to call it. She looked like she was sucking on a handful of change. Just horrible. Hateful face and for no reason whatsoever. But me, see, I've been at this a long time and I knew there was no way I was going to back off, not on this one. Because if nothing else this business has taught me how to read people. Not their books or whatever. But their inner, inner stuff. You know what I mean?
我试图配合她。也许，你知道，找点乐子，但她自动摆出了这种……这种表情。我不知道还能怎么称呼它。她看起来就像是在吮吸一把硬币。真是太可怕了。无缘无故地摆出一副仇恨的面孔。但我呢，你看，我干这一行很久了，我知道我绝不会退缩，这次不行。因为如果说这行教了我什么，那就是如何读懂人。不是读他们的书或者其他什么，而是读他们内在的、内在的东西。你知道我的意思吗？
All the psychological crap that makes them tick or whatever. So when Bobby Fingerton refused to dress like Aunt Jemima or Moms Mabely I suddenly got the message. That underneath all the praise, all the hoopla, she was ashamed of being black. And it was like, like a light went on in my head. It was like, bingo.
所有导致他们动力的心理废话之类的。所以当鲍比·芬格顿拒绝像杰米玛阿姨或妈妈·马布里那样打扮时，我突然明白了。在所有的赞扬、所有的喧嚣之下，她对自己的黑人身份感到羞耻。那感觉就像，像我脑子里亮了一盏灯。就像，宾果。
I always thought there was nothing worse than a tech rehearsal but that was before I met today's photographer. Because we're busy trying to open this play, I asked if he would mind coming to the theater. He set up his lights in the basement and greeted me saying, "You're a smoker aren't you? Do I have the right person?" I said, "Yes. I smoke." And he handed me a package of novelty cigarettes designed to look as though they were lit.
我一直认为没有什么比技术排练更糟糕了，但那是在我遇到今天的摄影师之前。因为我们忙着准备开演这部戏，我问他介不介意到剧院来。他在地下室架起灯光，迎接我时说：“你是吸烟者，对吧？我没找错人吧？”我说：“是的，我吸烟。”然后他递给我一包新奇的香烟，设计成好像已经点燃的样子。
"I want you to put these in your mouth," he said. "Not the individual cigarettes, but the whole package."
“我要你把这些放进嘴里，”他说，“不是单支香烟，是整包放进去。”
There were maybe three cigarettes altogether but what with the cardboard backing and the plastic cover, the package was the size of one of those soap carriers children sometimes take to camp. It was a tight and nasty tasting fit, but whenever you complain the photographers act like you're ruining not just their day but their entire life. This is their livelihood and here you are, spoiling it with your vanity.
总共可能也就三支香烟，但加上纸板背衬和塑料盖，这包装有孩子们有时带去露营的那些肥皂盒那么大。这又紧又难受，但每当你抱怨时，摄影师就表现得好像你不仅毁了他们的一天，还毁了他们的一生。这是他们的生计，而你却用你的虚荣心破坏了它。
The underlying message is that they're doing you a favor. Here you'll be in a magazine, people will read about you and maybe buy the book, shouldn't you be grateful? I thought of the people who might buy the book based on this picture, and then I withdrew the package from my mouth saying that it felt silly to me.
潜台词是他们是在帮你的忙。你会在杂志上露面，人们会读到你，也许会买这本书，你不应该心存感激吗？我想到那些可能会因为这张照片而买书的人，然后我把烟包从嘴里取出来，说这让我觉得很傻。
I thought I explained myself fairly well. The photographer crossed his arms and nodded in all the right places before saying, "What if we get you lying on the ground with an extension cord in your mouth? That might be fun. What do you say?"
我想我解释得够清楚了。摄影师交叉双臂，在所有合适的地方点着头，然后说：“如果我们让你躺在地上，嘴里咬着一根延长线呢？那可能很有趣。你觉得呢？”
So Bobby Fingerton gave me three options. She said I could either photograph her standing beside the window, seated at what I thought was a very pretentious desk made from the hatch of an old slave ship, or else I could leave. I mean, can you beat that? She's telling me what to do. Now, I wasn't about to lower myself to her level so I let her think that oh, she'd really busted my balls. Like, oh, I'm really hurting now. And I said, very formal like, I said, "All right then Ms. Fingerton, let's try you standing by the window."
所以鲍比·芬格顿给了我三个选择。她说要么拍她站在窗边，要么坐在我看来是用旧奴隶船舱口做成的极其自命不凡的办公桌前，要么我就走人。我的意思是，这你敢信？她在教我做事。现在，我可不会降低到她的水平，所以我让她以为，哦，她真的让我难堪了。就像，噢，我现在真的很受伤。然后我非常正式地说道：“好吧，芬格顿女士，我们试试你站在窗边吧。”
So she takes her post and I knocked off maybe two or three rolls. And then I had my assistant sneak outside and toss an M80 into her window box just to see what would happen. Talk about that a good hunch. What with the noise of the shattered glass her eyes, I swear on my mother's grave, the size of [LAUGHTER] coasters, and her mouth closed up into this perfect little circle that was just, that was just-- I mean, the word priceless doesn't even begin to do it justice. It was one of those moments when you know for certain that there is indeed a God and he's actually playing on your team. No questions asked.
于是她就位了，我拍了两三卷胶卷。然后我让我的助手溜到外面，往她的窗框里扔了一个M80鞭炮，看看会发生什么。说到直觉，那真是神来之笔。随着玻璃破碎的声响，我向我母亲的坟墓发誓，她的眼睛瞪得有杯垫那么大，嘴巴缩成一个完美的圆圈，那简直是……那简直是……我的意思是，“无价”这两个字根本不足以形容。那是你确定上帝确实存在而且站在你这一边的时刻之一。毫无疑问。
So, I got the whole thing on film, which was just an absolute gas. I still-- just last night I looked at it and gave myself a stomach ache I was laughing so hard. After the shot I took the best picture back to the studio and-- we have computers and so forth. So what I did was darken her skin a little and erase the view from her window. There's some flowering trees or whatever, but I blotted them out and replaced them with this field of watermelons that just stretched on and on forever. Because the whole thing just screamed Mammy. But in a good way, because-- I don't know when the last time you saw that movie, but Mammy was actually a very nurturing person.
所以，我把整个过程都拍了下来，这简直太绝了。我至今……就在昨晚我还看着照片，笑得肚子疼。拍摄结束后，我把最好的照片带回工作室……我们有电脑之类的。我所做的是把她的肤色调暗了一些，擦掉了窗外的景色。那里本来有些开花的树之类的，但我把它们涂掉，换成了一片延伸到天边的西瓜地。因为整张照片都在尖叫着“奶妈”（Mammy）。但那是好的意义上的，因为……我不知道你上次看那部电影是什么时候，但“奶妈”其实是一个非常有教养、有爱心的人。
The shot was-- I don't mean to brag or anything-- but it was pretty amazing in terms of being out there, approaching that line between funny and maybe too funny for certain kinds of people. The magazine decided to put it on the cover and once it came out the Fingerton crowed went absolutely bananas. I mean, her majesty wrote me a five page hate letter just teaming with spelling errors.
这张照片——我不是想吹牛什么的——但在处于那种在有趣和对某些人来说可能太过火之间的界限上，它相当令人惊叹。杂志决定把它放在封面上，一旦出版，芬格顿的粉丝就彻底疯了。我的意思是，女王陛下给我写了一封五页长的仇恨信，充满了拼写错误。
If she wants to continue publishing these books of hers, she really needs to lighten up and have some fun. To see her take this too seriously would actually cause me pain. You know what I mean? Stuff like this just tears me up. I swear it does.
如果她想继续出版她的这些书，她真的需要放轻松一点，找点乐子。看到她对此太严肃，其实会让我感到痛苦。你知道我的意思吗？这样的事情真的让我心碎。我发誓是真的。
David Sedaris read from his diaries. [? Toby Warey ?] played the photographer. Amy Sedaris played the woman silently listening at the bar.
大卫·塞达里斯朗读了他的日记。[托比·瓦瑞（Toby Warey）]饰演了摄影师。艾米·塞达里斯（Amy Sedaris）饰演了在吧台默默倾听的女子。
Act Two, The Good, the Bad and the Wacky. Wacky sells and wacky is being sold to us. From the new Carrot Top movie to reissues of 1950s lounge music to Nick at Night, souvenir lunch boxes from old TV shows, and lava lamps, and anything at all having to do with The Brady Bunch , there is a mass merchandising of pre-digestive kitsch in our American culture right now. And is that always a bad thing? Is it always somebody's cynical marketing idea? Is there good wackiness out there?
第二幕，好、坏与古怪。古怪好卖，古怪正在被兜售给我们。从新的“胡萝卜头”（Carrot Top）电影到50年代酒廊音乐的再版，再到“Nick at Night”频道、老电视节目的纪念品午餐盒、熔岩灯，以及任何与《布雷迪家族》（The Brady Bunch）有关的东西，我们的美国文化中正充斥着大规模的预消化式媚俗营销。这总是件坏事吗？这总是某个人的愤世嫉俗的营销点子吗？真的有好的古怪吗？
I mean, there are things that are wacky. I do believe in the concept of wacky but I agree with you that it's being misused horribly.
我的意思是，确实有古怪的东西。我相信古怪这个概念，但我同意你的看法，它被滥用得太可怕了。
Josh Glenn is editor of Hermenaut , a magazine that analyzes pop culture in all sorts of ways. And we asked him for guidance in distinguishing in the flood of wacky that surrounds us, between good wacky and bad wacky. Glenn says if we want to understand this we have to begin with the way that things are made, the intent behind them. Some products and films and books which end up classified as wacky are things that were created without any kind of wacky intent.
乔什·格伦（Josh Glenn）是《赫尔墨特》（Hermenaut）杂志的编辑，该杂志以各种方式分析流行文化。我们请他指导我们在周围涌动的古怪浪潮中分辨好古怪和坏古怪。格伦说，如果我们想了解这一点，就必须从事物的制造方式、背后的意图开始。有些产品、电影和书籍被归类为古怪，但它们在创造时并没有任何古怪的意图。
Objects in films and songs that were created in pure earnestness, meant to be taken seriously. And then, at the other end of the scale, there are things that are created from the outset with the intention of being wacky.
电影和歌曲中的物品是以纯粹的诚意创作出来的，旨在被严肃对待。然后，在天平的另一端，有些东西从一开始就是为了古怪而创作的。
The daffy, the zany. Like Bugs Bunny cartoons, Jim Carrey movies, Adam Sandler. Stuff that, you know, it was created wackily and it's meant to be received wackily. I don't have a problem with that.
那些滑稽的、疯狂的。比如兔八哥卡通，金·凯瑞（Jim Carrey）电影，亚当·桑德勒（Adam Sandler）。那些你知道是古怪地创作出来，也打算被古怪地接收的东西。我对此没什么意见。
You don't have a problem with that?
你对此没意见？
No. I mean, I like Adam Sandler movies a lot. I hate Jim Carrey, but Adam Sandler is great. That's wackiness done really well. Three Stooges I used to watch a lot when I was a kid. Vaudeville stuff, that's wacky.
不。我的意思是，我挺喜欢亚当·桑德勒的电影。我讨厌金·凯瑞，但亚当·桑德勒很棒。那是做得很好的古怪。《三个臭皮匠》（Three Stooges）我小时候常看。杂耍那一套，那才叫古怪。
It's interesting because I never thought about it this way before, but there simply is wacky which is done better and wacky which is done worse.
这很有趣，因为我以前从没想过这一点，但确实存在做得比较好的古怪，也存在做得比较差的古怪。
Yeah.
是的。
没错。
Now, here's the thing. And here's where I think the out of whack is confused with the wacky in our culture, if you will. The way these cultural products are created and the way they are received obviously don't always line up just right. Something that was created with a great deal of earnestness might completely fail at what it was trying to do.
现在，问题在这儿。我认为这就是为什么在我们的文化中，“不合常理”与“古怪”被混淆的原因，如果你愿意这么说的话。这些文化产品的创作方式和接收方式显然并不总是完全对齐。有些带着极高诚意创作的东西可能完全没达到目的。
Let's take an example.
让我们举个例子。
If you think of, like, Ed Wood movies as a classic example. He wasn't joking when he made Plan 9 From Outer Space He was trying to make a science fiction movie. He thought it was a good movie. I'm not saying that he was in earnest in the sense that he was trying to uplift us or anything, he was just trying to entertain us. But it was a very in earnest attempt to make a good science fiction movie. He failed completely because he's a terrible director.
如果你想到艾德·伍德（Ed Wood）的电影作为一个经典例子。他在制作《外太空九号计划》（Plan 9 From Outer Space）时可没在开玩笑，他试图制作一部科幻电影。他觉得那是一部好电影。我不是说他有那种试图提升我们境界的诚意，他只是想娱乐我们。但那是非常诚恳地尝试制作一部好的科幻电影。他彻底失败了，因为他是个糟糕的导演。
However, he had a really original vision and he wasn't being wacky. he wasn't just trying to make us split our sides at watching his movies. Like Jim Carrey's movies. Everything that's out of whack is not wacky. If you see what I'm saying. So when I go into a video store and I see an Ed Wood movie and it's package wackily and they talk about the wacky vision of Ed Wood on the back cover, that's aggravating.
然而，他有一个真正独特的愿景，他并不是在装疯卖傻。他并不是想让我们在看他的电影时笑得前仰后合，不像金·凯瑞的电影。并不是所有不合常理的东西都是“古怪”的。如果你明白我的意思的话。所以当我去录像带店看到一部艾德·伍德的电影，封面上被包装得很古怪，封底上还谈论着艾德·伍德的古怪愿景，那真是令人恼火。
And Plan 9 From Outer Space is just wacky. and if you rent it all, which you probably wouldn't, you'd rent it when you feel like laughing at something. Having a sort of hipper than thou evening, I guess. It's great that they found some way to sell them, get them in the stores. You know, whatever. I'm happy to rent a movie that's package is wacky if that's what it takes to get it in the store.
而《外太空九号计划》确实很古怪。如果你租来看——你可能不会，你只有在想嘲笑点什么的时候才会租。过一个比别人更时髦的夜晚，我想。很高兴他们找到了一些方法把它们卖出去，放进商店里。你知道，管他呢。如果这能让它进店，我很乐意租一部包装得很古怪的电影。
However, I think you could also talk about the wackification of American culture, where we are really not allowed to see anything that's between earnest and silly. When, of course, you can look at all kinds of cultural products that were meant to be taken very seriously and find them funny. Yet, at the same time, have a lot of respect for them or find them beautiful or find them moving. There's all kinds of more emotionally engaged ways you can deal with failed seriousness.
不过，我认为你也可以谈论美国文化的“古怪化”，在那里我们真的不被允许看到任何介于严肃和愚蠢之间的东西。当然，你可以看各种原本打算被非常严肃对待的文化产品，却觉得它们很有趣。但同时，对它们怀有极大的敬意，或者觉得它们很美，或觉得它们很动人。处理失败的严肃性，有各种更具情感参与的方式。
Like for example you, what would be something like that?
比如你，那会是什么样的例子？
For me, like ABBA for instance. ABBA is an example of failed seriousness. Their music is not intended to be funny. It's extremely overly passionate, overly dripping with emotion and sentimentality in a way that we find hilarious now. Yet, at the same time, they meant it. And if can sort of engage with what they were trying to do, you can both laugh in it, and be very moved by it.
对我来说，比如ABBA乐队。ABBA就是失败的严肃性的一个例子。他们的音乐本意不是要搞笑。它极其过度煽情，情感和感伤流露得太过分，以至于我们现在觉得很滑稽。但与此同时，他们是认真的。如果你能参与到他们试图做的事情中，你既可以笑它，也可以被它深深打动。
And that's your relation to it. That's what you feel about ABBA.
那是你与它的关系。这就是你对ABBA的感受。
Josh Glenn. His essay in the latest issue of Hermenaut distinguishes between two reactions to wackiness or kitsch. Those two reactions, camp, a kind of loving, emotionally engaged response, and cheese, which sneers at it.
乔什·格伦。他在最新一期《赫尔墨特》杂志上的文章区分了对古怪或媚俗的两种反应。这两种反应是：坎普（Camp），一种充满爱意、情感参与的反应；以及芝士（Cheese），一种嘲讽的态度。
Act Three, The Politics of Wackiness. Some of the most interesting reporting in the 1996 presidential election was by Michael Lewis, who published his campaign diaries in the New Republic magazine and then wrote a book, Trail Fever , from those diaries. Before that he wrote a book called Liar's Poker about his years working on Wall Street.
第三幕，古怪的政治学。1996年总统大选中一些最有趣的报道来自迈克尔·刘易斯，他在《新共和》杂志上发表了他的竞选日记，后来根据这些日记写了一本书，《竞选热》（Trail Fever）。在此之前，他写过一本名为《说谎者的扑克牌》（Liar's Poker）的书，关于他在华尔街工作的那几年。
On the campaign trail he noticed that the candidates who tended to have any original ideas at all, the candidates who were the most interesting, were usually pegged by the media as being, guess, wacky.
在竞选活动中，他注意到那些往往有原创想法的候选人，那些最有趣的候选人，通常会被媒体贴上——你猜对了——“古怪”的标签。
I think that it's not just in politics but also in big business. I think you find that anybody who's got the ring of authenticity, anybody who behaves the way real human beings behave in a context where powerful men are engaged in their epic struggle for power, gets tagged with being wacky, or being offbeat or oddball. I mean, there's nothing more alarming or dissonant in national politics than a politician that tells the truth and talks like a ordinary human being talks. As opposed to the way a national politician talks.
我认为这不仅在政治领域，在大型商业领域也是如此。你会发现任何具有真实感的人，任何在权势男人为权力进行史诗般斗争的背景下表现得像真正人类的人，都会被贴上古怪、不走寻常路或怪人的标签。我的意思是，在国家政治中，没有什么比一个说真话、像普通人那样说话的政客更令人警觉或不协调的了。这与国家政客通常说话的方式截然不同。
So let me ask you to give an example of a candidate like this.
所以让我请你举一个这样的候选人的例子。
Probably the best example is Morry Taylor. He was this guy who'd come out of the midwest who ran a, what? A billion and a half dollar company and whose workers adored him and who was qualified in every way really to be talking about some of the big problems that faced the country. But because he was funny and because he didn't take himself or the process all too seriously, he got tagged as being kind of odd and offbeat and not serious.
最好的例子可能是莫里·泰勒（Morry Taylor）。他是一个从中西部走出来的家伙，经营着一家……什么？价值15亿美元的公司，他的员工爱戴他，他确实在各个方面都有资格谈论国家面临的一些大问题。但因为他很风趣，因为他并没有把自己或竞选过程看得太严肃，他被贴上了古怪、另类且不严肃的标签。
He talked-- he was the only guy I met on the whole campaign trail who was running for office who talked to me the way normal people talk. And who made sense to me in some ways. And yet, precisely for that reason, he was marginalized. And considered wacky, considered not to be a serious contender, not to be the sort of person who could get elected president.
他说话……他是我在整个竞选过程中遇到的唯一一个像正常人那样跟我说话的竞选者。在某些方面他说得很有道理。然而，恰恰因为这个原因，他被边缘化了。他被认为是古怪的，被认为不是严肃的竞争者，不是那种可以当选总统的人。
And he had serious ideas as well, right?
而且他也有严肃的想法，对吧？
Oh, very serious ideas. In fact, when you took his ideas, when you stripped them away from the man and you just pulled the ideas, he routinely beat Clinton and Dole. I mean, people would say, we want that platform as opposed to the Clinton platform or the Dole platform. His platform was perfectly respectable. It was that it was being presented-- the problem wasn't the message, it was the messenger. That the messenger was a real person. And that was not, that's not what you do in politics.
噢，非常严肃的想法。事实上，当你把他的想法剥离出来，去掉他的人格魅力，只看想法本身时，他经常击败克林顿和多尔。人们会说，我们想要那个平台，而不是克林顿或多尔的平台。他的平台非常体面。问题在于它的呈现方式……问题不在于信息本身，而在于传递信息的人。传递者是一个真实的人。而在政治中，你不能那样做。
You're not allowed to be funny. You're not allowed to be funny, I'll put in another way, you're not allowed to be funny when you're also serious at the same time. The jokes have a certain place. But funny serious doesn't really work.
你不被允许幽默。换个说法，当你同时还要严肃时，你不被允许幽默。笑话在政治中有一个固定的位置。但“风趣又严肃”真的行不通。
Like, what's the place of the jokes?
就像，笑话的位置是什么？
A joke is, in politics, something you tell at the beginning of your serious speech and everybody knows it's the joke because it's the beginning of the speech and it's the one about the three farmers in Iowa. It's not actually funny. It's a ritual joke. But to be actually funny, that's dangerous. To use humor as a way of conveying ideas, that's not so good. It makes people nervous.
在政治中，笑话是你在这个严肃演讲开始时讲的段子，每个人都知道这是个笑话，因为它在演讲开头，讲的是爱荷华州三个农民的那个笑话。它其实一点都不好笑。那是个仪式性的笑话。但要真正做到风趣，那很危险。利用幽默来传达观点，这不太好。这会让人们感到不安。
I remember one of the most memorable scenes in Trail Fever , when you were out there, is that you had heard about Alan Keyes, Republican candidate, very serious guy. And you'd heard about him and you were anticipating he was going to be completely wacky, from what you had heard.
我记得《竞选热》中最难忘的场景之一是，你当时在那儿，听说共和党候选人艾伦·凯斯（Alan Keyes）是一个非常严肃的人。你听说过他，本来以为根据传闻他会完全是个怪人。
Wacky is putting it kindly. I thought he was possibly insane. All you heard about this guy was there's this crazy black man running for the Republican nomination. And nobody takes him seriously. But when you actually got out there with him--
用“怪人”已经很客气了。我当时觉得他可能疯了。关于这家伙你只能听到说“有一个疯狂的黑人在竞选共和党提名”。没人把他当回事。但当你真正和他在一起时……
Then you actually went and saw one of his speeches.
然后你真的去看了一场他的演讲。
And it was the most extraordinary thing. I mean, he was in the middle of the dead of a winner, in the middle of a snowstorm, in the middle of Iowa. 500 farmers turn out hear Alan Keyes say what he has to say. And it turns out that he's speaking very sincerely to what people want to hear. He had a single message. And the message was, look America, all you want to talk about is money and money problems, the deficit, taxes, so on and so forth. But the real problems in this country are moral problems, not money problems. He was genuinely a moralist.
那是极其非凡的时刻。我的意思是，在仲冬，在暴风雪中，在爱荷华州的中心地带。500名农民出来听艾伦·凯斯发表讲话。结果发现他是非常真诚地在说人们想听的话。他只有一个信息。这个信息是：看好了，美国，你们关心的全都是钱和金钱问题、赤字、税收等等。但这个国家真正的问题是道德问题，而不是金钱问题。他真是一个道德家。
And the way he presented his views was pulpit thumping. I mean, he would burn the paint off the walls when he talked. It was the most extraordinary display of oratorical skill. But even that, in fact, doesn't really have its place in presidential politics anymore because it's extreme, it's entertaining. That's not what you do.
他呈现观点的方式是那种抨击讲坛式的。我的意思是，他说话时能把墙上的漆烧掉。那是我见过的最非凡的演讲技巧展示。但即便如此，在总统政治中它其实已经没有地位了，因为它太极端，太具有娱乐性。这不是你该做的事。
I mean, the phoniest candidates in some ways were taken the most serious simply because they were phony. Lamar Alexander was taken seriously for no reason other than he was a great phony and people assume that great phonies succeed in that process. Anybody who was authentic, or had any kind of integrity started with one strike against them because people just assumed, or reporters just assumed, that this character isn't suited for the process.
我的意思是，那些最虚伪的候选人在某种程度上反而被视为最严肃的，仅仅因为他们是虚伪的。拉马尔·亚历山大（Lamar Alexander）被认真对待，原因无他，就是因为他是一个伟大的伪君子，而人们认为伟大的伪君子在那种过程中往往会成功。任何真诚或有某种正直感的人，一开始就面临着打击，因为人们——或者记者们——仅仅是假设这个角色不适合这个流程。
It's interesting because the same thing-- I'm just thinking about what you're saying about how serious and funny aren't allowed to coexist in the same person. In the news itself, in a certain way, like in the way the news media covers things, series and funny are segregated usually. In mainstream news, think about the network news.
这很有趣，因为同样的事情……我正在思考你说的关于“严肃”和“有趣”如何在同一个人身上不被允许共存。在新闻本身中，以某种方式，就像新闻媒体报道事物的方式，严肃和有趣通常是隔离的。在主流新闻中，想想电视网新闻。
Oh yes. The anchors, if you really look at them, they will tell you, oh, now we-- every now and then they might do something that's a joke, and they tell the joke about the spaghetti harvest in Italy where people are actually getting spaghetti off of trees, or whatever it is they're doing, some joke story. But it's a joke story. If you're doing a serious story, humor is never allowed to creep into it.
噢，是的。主播们，如果你仔细看，他们会告诉你……哦，现在我们……他们偶尔会开个玩笑，讲讲意大利面收成的笑话，人们真的在树上摘意大利面，或者他们正在做的什么事，某种笑话故事。但那是专门的笑话报道。如果你在做严肃新闻，幽默绝不允许渗透进去。
You ask why that is. I mean, it's a great question why that is. I think it's because the people who are in the seriousness business, big businessmen, national politicians, national news reporters, one of their great fears is to be taken unseriously. That they're seriousness what they're selling. And they can never let that guard down, because if they let it down then all of a sudden they open themselves to a different kind of criticism. Oh, he's not a serious person.
你问为什么会这样。我的意思是，这是一个很好的问题。我想这是因为从事“严肃”行业的人，大商人、国家政客、国家新闻记者，他们最大的恐惧之一就是不被认真对待。严肃是他们售卖的产品。他们永远不能放松警惕，因为如果放松了，他们突然就会招致另一种批评：“哦，他不是个严肃的人。”
Do you think we actually pay a political price as a nation for this kind of segregation that we do between seriousness on the one hand and wackiness on the other? That is, everybody gets classified or seems to get classified in political life-- you're either one or the other and there's very little middle ground. You're either the super serious candidate, a little pompous, or you're just discarded as the kind of wacky goofball. Including people who are very serious like Pat Buchanan.
你认为作为一个国家，我们是否因为在严肃和古怪之间这种隔离做法而付出了政治代价？也就是说，每个人在政治生活中似乎都被归类了——你要么是这个，要么是那个，几乎没有中间地带。你要么是那个有点自命不凡的超严肃候选人，要么就被贬为那种古怪的笨蛋。包括像帕特·布坎南（Pat Buchanan）这样非常严肃的人也难逃此列。
It's very clear that the price you pay is you don't get a very honest public debate. There are lots of things you can't say just because it doesn't sound right. And sounding right is all important. And sounding right means being serious all the time.
很明显，你付出的代价就是得不到诚实的公共辩论。有很多事情你不能说，仅仅因为听起来不太对。而“听起来正确”是一切的重点。听起来正确意味着时刻保持严肃。
The second price you pay, and it's hard to measure, is that no one is interested. It doesn't ring true the way issues are discussed. It does seem like people just posturing. And the reason it seems that way is because that's what they're doing.
你付出的第二个代价，而且很难衡量，就是没人感兴趣。议题讨论的方式听起来不真实。人们看起来只是在摆姿势。而它看起来像那样的原因是，他们确实就在那么做。
Michael Lewis. Author of the book Trail Fever.
迈克尔·刘易斯。《竞选热》一书的作者。
Coming up, what the truly wacky do with the nation's leading business newspaper. How Peter Jennings can help you evade wackiness and seriousness. And Sarah Vowel, A Streetcar Named Desire , and William Shatner together in the same story. That's in a minute. From Public Radio International when our program continues.
即将播出：真正古怪的人是如何处理全国领先的商业报纸的。彼得·詹宁斯（Peter Jennings）如何帮助你规避古怪与严肃。还有莎拉·沃威尔、《欲望号街车》和威廉·夏特纳（William Shatner）出现在同一个故事里。一分钟后回来。节目继续，来自国际公共广播电台。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Death to Wacky. Or, rather, 13 ways to describe wacky. And in our irrepressible, madcap style, we've now skipped to Act Eleven. This program goes to 11. Self-Made Wacky.
这是《这就是美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周节目中，我们当然会选择一个主题，为你带来各种不同类型的相关故事。今天的节目，去他的古怪。或者说，看待古怪的13种方式。以我们不可抑制的、疯狂的风格，我们现在跳到第十一幕。这节目要播到11呢。自称古怪。
Not all wackiness is, of course, created by marketers and merchandisers. No, no, no, no, no. It occurs in nature. Some people simply see themselves as wacky. Take this personals ad from the Chicago Reader . "Joining the firm. Fun, sensual, buxom, brilliant blond SWF seeks never married SWM, 34-41, exercise partner who also has adipose tissue to melt and would enjoy burning calories, regaining fitness, with wacky, warm, enthusiastic partner. A definite physical fitness relationship. Maybe more? Sincere replies only." So we gave her a call.
当然，并不是所有的古怪都是由营销人员和推销员创造的。不不不不，不。它自然存在。有些人只是把自己看作古怪的人。看看《芝加哥读者》（Chicago Reader）上的这则个人广告：“加入公司。有趣、感性、胸部丰满、才华横溢的金发单身白人女性，寻求从未结婚的单身白人男性，34-41岁，健身伙伴，同时也想融化脂肪，喜欢燃烧卡路里、恢复健康，拥有一个古怪、热情、充满活力的伴侣。一段明确的身体健身关系。也许更多？只接受真诚回复。”所以我们给她打了电话。
I think maybe I'm just a little bit unconventional. My friends do call me wacky. I mean, they think I'm pretty open-minded and just a very spontaneous kind of person. And I think that's what they really consider wacky to be. And maybe also just the different things that I'm involved with, like, perhaps, I know how to speak six foreign languages.
我想也许我只是有点不走寻常路。我的朋友们确实叫我古怪。我的意思是，他们觉得我很开明，只是一个非常自发的人。我想那才是他们真正认为“古怪”所代表的意思。也许还有我参与的不同事情，比如，也许，我知道怎么说六种外语。
Wow.
哇。
So, you know, I'll start with a language, or I'll be listening to somebody with a conversation, and then I'll just kind of like, slide right in, not even knowing the people. And they think it's very, they think it's kind of a wacky kind of a thing to do. And maybe sometimes, not all the time, in college once I pretended to be a foreign exchange student.
所以，你知道，我会用某种语言开头，或者我会听某人谈话，然后我就那样，直接插进去，甚至不认识这些人。他们觉得这非常……他们觉得这是一种挺古怪的行为。还有有时候，不是总是，在大学里有一次我假装成外籍交换生。
And different maybe parties I've thrown in the past. Like, you know, bring your favorite wig or Wall Street Journal party. Some kind of--
还有我过去举办的一些不同的派对。比如，你知道，带你最喜欢的假发或《华尔街日报》派对。某种……
Bring your favorite wig or Wall Street Journal . That the choice? A wig or the Wall Street Journal?
带你最喜欢的假发或《华尔街日报》。那是选项？假发还是《华尔街日报》？
No, no, no, no. Bring your favorite wig party or a Wall Street Journal party or something like that.
不不不不。带你最喜欢的假发派对，或者《华尔街日报》派对之类的。
What happens at a Wall Street Journal party?
在《华尔街日报》派对上会发生什么？
You have everybody bring the Wall Street Journal , the Wall Street Journals , and you put them all over the floor and the walls and everything. It's just, you know, one of the Wall Street Journal parties, that's all.
你让每个人都带《华尔街日报》，那些报纸，然后把它们贴得满地满墙到处都是。这只是，你知道，其中一种《华尔街日报》派对，就是这样。
And then what happens?
然后呢，会发生什么？
And that's it. That's all. Just something fun and maybe out of the ordinary instead of, you know, just having a regular party, just tell everybody, bring a copy of the Wall Street Journal and you have a Wall Street Journal party.
就这样。完了。只是点好玩的，也许是不寻常的，而不是你知道的，只是办个普通派对，就告诉大家，带一份《华尔街日报》，你就有了《华尔街日报》派对。
And then you just tape it  up to  the walls--
然后你就把它贴在墙上——
Yeah, tape it up to the the walls or around the floor.
是的，贴在墙上或者铺在地板周围。
And you put it on the floor--
然后你把它放在地板上——
Whatever. You know, that's it.
随便。你知道，就是那样。
What happens after a few hours at a Wall Street Journal party? Do people talk about the Wall Street Journal ?
在《华尔街日报》派对上几个小时后会发生什么？人们会谈论《华尔街日报》吗？
Yeah, they'll talk about what they've read or what's been happening. They'll give different critiques and different things and the current events that have been happening or something like that.
会，他们会讨论他们读到的内容或发生了什么事。他们会给出不同的评论和不同的事情，以及正在发生的时事之类的。
You know, I've got to say, you know, that is wacky.
你知道，我得说，那是挺古怪的。
Yeah.
是的。
You know there's a kind of person who likes being called wacky and a kind of person who doesn't. It seems like you're pretty comfortable with it.
你知道有一种人喜欢被称为“古怪”，也有一种人不喜欢。看起来你对此很自在。
Yeah. It doesn't bother me. I don't take it as a negative thing and I don't take it as a positive thing. I think it's just an observation.
是的。它不困扰我。我不把它当作负面的东西，也不把它当作正面的东西。我认为这只是一个观察。
And do you think it's wackiness when people call you back for the personalize ads?
你觉得当人们因为个人广告回电给你时，那算是古怪吗？
Hm-mmm.
嗯。
One of the things that we've been told by marketing people in this week's show is that wacky sells.
本周节目中营销人员告诉我们的一件事是，古怪好卖。
Yeah, wacky sells, right.
是的，古怪好卖，对吧。
And are you finding that's true with you?
你觉得这在你身上也适用吗？
I think that wacky does sell. I think that wacky sells because people are so afraid to be wacky and so they want to tap into that thing that makes them curious about what wacky is all about. And that wacky people do things that unwacky people are too frightened or too conservative to do.
我认为古怪确实好卖。我认为古怪好卖是因为人们太害怕表现得古怪了，所以他们想触及那个让他们好奇古怪到底是怎么一回事的东西。而且古怪的人做的那些事，不古怪的人太害怕或太保守而不敢去做。
So how many responses have you gotten to your ad?
那么你收到了多少回应？
I have gotten probably about 30 responses, which I think is pretty good.
我大概收到了30个回应，我觉得这挺不错的。
And of those have any of them mentioned the wackiness?
其中有人提到过“古怪”吗？
Some have mentioned the wackiness, yes.
有些人提到了古怪，是的。
They have?
真的吗？
Hm-mmm.
嗯。
Because I guess I was wondering if you think that it's wacky that's selling, or if you think it's more like, you know, fun, sensual, buxom, brilliant blond.
因为我猜我在想，你觉得是“古怪”这个词在起作用，还是更像是，你知道，有趣、感性、胸部丰满、才华横溢的金发美女？
Oh, come on. What do you think? I think the wacky puts them at ease. My intention with wacky is, number one, it was very-- it's an honest description. And number two, I think it kind of puts people at ease, too, to not think that I'm some kind of fashion model or some very serious person that only perfect GQ men must apply to my ad and I won't consider anybody else.
噢，得了吧。你觉得呢？我认为“古怪”让人们放松了。我对古怪的意图，第一，它很……它是一个诚实的描述。第二，我认为它也让人们感到放松，不至于认为我是一个什么时尚模特，或者是一个只有完美的《GQ》杂志男士才必须申请我的广告，而不考虑其他任何人。
Right. Sensual, buxom, brilliant blonde might be a little intimidating.
没错。感性、胸部丰满、才华横溢的金发美女可能会有点吓人。
Right. Exactly. So you know, wacky and warm is part of my package too.
没错。正是这样。所以你知道，古怪和热情也是我包装的一部分。
And it's selling.
而且它卖出去了。
Yeah. Exactly.
是的。正是这样。
Maria. And advertiser in the Chicago Reader .
玛丽亚，《芝加哥读者》的一位广告商。
Act Twelve, Evading Wacky and Serious. As we've said in this show, if you're in certain kinds of jobs, business, politics, the news, there are lots of jobs actually, and you're funny, you're encouraged to either suppress that side of yourself or simply become the wacky guy. You can either be Edward R. Murrow or Andy Rooney. And of course nobody is going to send Andy Rooney to cover the Oklahoma City bombing or something serious.
第十二幕，规避古怪与严肃。正如我们在节目中所说，如果你从事某些特定的工作，商业、政治、新闻，其实有很多工作，而你很风趣，你会被鼓励要么压抑自己那一部分，要么干脆变成“古怪的那家伙”。你要么做爱德华·R·默罗（Edward R. Murrow），要么做安迪·鲁尼（Andy Rooney）。当然没人会派安迪·鲁尼去报道俄克拉荷马城爆炸案或什么严肃事件。
But in that landscape there  are all sorts of people who avoid being pushed into either box, people whose work has serious intent and humor and lots else besides. Robert Krulwich is somebody like that. His news stories on NPR, and CBS, and ABC are surprising and like no one else's. I still remember today a fake opera called Grosso Interesa that he must have staged-- it must have been 15 years ago on NPR'S All Things Considered using the voice of the chairman of the federal reserve laced into actual operatic music to explain and analyze Reaganomics.
但在那个领域里，有各种各样的人避免被推入任何一个框框，那些人的作品既有严肃的意图，也有幽默，还有其他很多东西。罗伯特·克鲁尔维奇（Robert Krulwich）就是这样的人。他在NPR、CBS和ABC上的新闻报道令人惊喜，与众不同。直到今天，我还记得他十几年前在NPR的《全时考虑》（All Things Considered）节目中策划的一出伪歌剧，叫《Grosso Interesa》，使用了联邦储备委员会主席的声音，编织进真正的歌剧音乐里，来解释和分析里根经济学。
Krulwich says the thing about trying to occupy this territory that is neither super serious nor wacky, this middle territory, is that sometimes people simply do not know what to make of it. And you stumble into all these unexpected responses.
克鲁尔维奇说，试图占据这种既不超严肃也不古怪的中间领域，意味着有时人们根本不知道该怎么对待它。你会陷入各种意想不到的反应中。
For example, one time on the Peter Jennings program on ABC News I decided and he decided, he agreed, we'd do a series during one of the Olympics seasons, we'd do a series in which I created something called the Insect Olympics. Where I chose I think five insects who could outperform the human champion by a multiple of at least 20, as I recall. And it was done with pure joy and we took it very seriously. So we were very careful to select the strongest or the fastest or the best in whatever category it was insect and then choose the equivalent human being.
举个例子，有一次在彼得·詹宁斯的ABC新闻节目上，我决定，他同意了，我们要在奥运赛季做一系列节目，我创建了一个叫“昆虫奥林匹克”的东西。我选了我想是五种能够以至少20倍的倍数胜过人类冠军的昆虫。这是纯粹出于快乐而做的，我们非常认真地对待它。所以我们非常仔细地选择了某种类别里最强、最快或最好的昆虫，然后选择相应的人类选手。
So what happened the first night of this series is I had chosen speed, there was going to be a sprint. And the fastest sprinter in the world was an American, a black American. And the fastest insect in the world-- and we had a real runoff here between the entomology departments at Cornell, University Illinois, and I think the winner was out on the west coast, between two different insects, but the one that one was the cockroach.
所以那个系列节目的第一晚发生了什么，我选择了速度，要进行短跑比赛。世界上最快的短跑运动员是一个美国人，一个黑人美国人。而世界上最快的昆虫……我们当时在康奈尔大学、伊利诺伊大学的昆虫学系之间进行了一场真正的竞争，我想赢家是在西海岸的某个昆虫，但最终胜出的是蟑螂。
Cockroaches go incredibly fast. We set up this elaborate system where we had a treadmill, and there was this cockroach going an incredibly fast speed, jumping over little-- it was wonderful to see. And, by the way, when cockroaches go really fast, they go up on their back legs, their front legs are up in the air so they're bipedal, just like we are. So there's even like an equivalency. Anyway, I was totally enraptured by this thing. I thought it had great teacherlyness, it had great humor, it had great wisdom, and all the things you flatter yourself about.
蟑螂跑得难以置信地快。我们建立了一个精密的系统，那里有个跑步机，蟑螂以惊人的速度奔跑，跳过小障碍物……看这个太棒了。顺便说一句，蟑螂跑得很快时，它们会用后腿站立，前腿抬在空中，所以它们是双足行走的，就像我们一样。所以甚至还有某种等效性。总之，我当时完全被这东西迷住了。我觉得它很有教育意义，很有幽默感，很有智慧，所有那些你自吹自擂的特质它都有。
We put it on television and the lights on the switchboard started lighting up almost immediately on Peter's desk, at my desk, in my office, and all over the newsroom. Black Americans all over the country look at this thing, and they're thinking we have this champion human being, who happens to be our race, and this [BLEEP] on television goes up and compares us to vermin. That's how they see the cockroach.
我们在电视上播出了它，彼得桌上、我桌上、我办公室里以及整个新闻编辑室的交换机指示灯几乎立刻亮了起来。全国各地的黑人都在看这个节目，他们想：我们有这个人类冠军，恰好是我们这个种族，电视上这个[哔——]却跑出来把我们比作害虫。他们就是那样看待蟑螂的。
Of course, if you think about it, of course cockroaches have a very bad reputation. But I'd gotten so into the insect world I'd lost the sense that cockroaches are bad news, or have a bad reputation. So I'm picking up the phone and one person after another is accusing me. And here you are in the joy of the moment. You've created this thing that you're so proud of. And then you're so ashamed by the second call. So ashamed. And it was awful.
当然，如果你想一想，蟑螂的名声确实很臭。但我已经深入到昆虫世界，以至于失去了那种“蟑螂是个坏东西”或“名声不佳”的概念。所以我接起电话，一个人接一个人地指责我。而你本处于快乐的时刻。你创造了你自己如此引以为傲的东西。然后第二个电话就让你感到无比羞愧。无比羞愧。那太糟糕了。
Then Peter Jennings did this amazing thing, I thought, which gives you a sense of how subtle television can get when it wants to. He said, well, what's on tomorrow night? I was worried he was going to say, let's chuck the whole thing I can't take the heat. But instead he said, what's on tomorrow night? I said, well, we have a rhinoceros beetle who is going to outperform a Chinese weight lifter. He says, OK.
然后彼得·詹宁斯做了这件令人惊叹的事情，我想，这让你感觉到电视在它想做得精细时能达到什么程度。他说：嗯，明晚播什么？我当时担心他会说，“算了，把整个节目砍了吧，我受不了这压力。”但相反，他说：明晚播什么？我说：好吧，我们有个犀牛甲虫，它将击败一名中国举重运动员。他说：好的。
Then he says to me, I'm going to really like tomorrow's piece. Then he walks away. I have no idea what that means. Really like? He kind of liked this one. So I tune on the TV the next night and he's sitting there and he says-- first, when it comes to the end of the show, and this is going be the piece, he lights up, his face just turns like all happy. And he says and now something really special. A lot of you called yesterday, we share your fascination-- I mean, I was just thinking-- with the human relations between the species and blah blah blah.
然后他对我说了句：我会非常喜欢明天的片段。然后他就走开了。我根本不知道那是什么意思。非常喜欢？他刚才那个片段也挺喜欢的。所以我在第二天晚上打开电视，他坐在那儿，他说……首先，节目快结束时，也就是这个片段要播出时，他亮了起来，脸变得非常快乐。他说：现在是特别片段。昨天很多人打来电话，我们分享你们的着迷……我的意思是，我刚才还在想……关于人类种族间的关系等等等等。
And then he says, like almost licking his lips, now let's watch this. It had the effect of somebody stepping up at their own dinner table and saying, I cooked this meatloaf, let's taste this. I mean, it would have been very bad manners at that moment not to like what followed. But after it was over he did a non-verbal act which was very interesting. The piece ends and he just sits there silently glowing. It's the only way I could describe it.
然后他说，几乎是舔着嘴唇：现在让我们看看这个。这感觉就像有人在自己的餐桌前站起来说：我做了这道肉饼，来尝尝吧。我的意思是，那一刻如果不喜欢接下来要播出的内容，那是非常糟糕的礼貌。但在节目结束后，他做了一个非常有趣的非语言行为。片段结束了，他就坐在那里默默地发光。我只能这样形容。
And then he sucks in his breath and he goes on. In other news, blah blah blah. And that act by the anchor, and this has happened to me with Susan Stamberg at NPR, other anchors too who just-- If they insist that this isn't wacky. If they say, no, I'm the man in the center, I'm the center of gravity here, the center likes this, then you do. Then you do. The calls went 180 degrees the other direction. Wonderful, marvelous.
然后他倒吸一口气，继续说：其他新闻……云云。主播的那个举动，我在NPR的苏珊·斯坦伯格（Susan Stamberg）和其他主播身上也遇到过……如果他们坚持说这不是古怪。如果他们说：“不，我是中间的那个人，我是这里的重心，重心喜欢这个。”那么你就也喜欢。那么你就也喜欢。电话里的风向立刻180度大转弯。太美妙了，太神奇了。
And I have to assign it, I think, mostly not to the substance of the two pieces but to Peter's display.
我想，我得把这归功于彼得的表现，而不是那两个片段本身的内容。
Robert Krulwich is a correspondent for ABC News. He is currently working on a serious history of the United States told from the point of view of Barbie.
罗伯特·克鲁尔维奇是ABC新闻的记者。他目前正在创作一部严肃的美国历史，从芭比娃娃的角度来讲述。
Act Thirteen, Dr. Jeckyl and Mr. Wacky. Now with this examination of the split in our culture that creates wacky, the split that demands that things either be totally serious or totally goofy, we have this story from our contributing editor Sarah Vowel.
第十三幕，杰基尔医生与古怪先生。现在，随着对造成“古怪”的文化裂痕的考察，那种要求事物要么彻底严肃要么彻底愚蠢的裂痕，我们有了来自我们特约编辑莎拉·沃威尔的这个故事。
One of the most gut wrenching half hours of public radio each week is a program produced in Chicago called Magnificent Obsession . It listens in on recovering drug and alcohol addicts telling their stories. Some are hopeful, some are funny, but many are just harrowing. The drunken mother crawling, literally crawling, out of stores with her children in tow. The teenager whose parents find her lying in her own vomit.
每周公共广播中最令人心碎的半小时节目之一是芝加哥制作的节目，叫《宏大痴迷》（Magnificent Obsession）。它倾听康复中的毒品和酒精成瘾者讲述他们的故事。有些充满希望，有些很有趣，但许多只是让人痛苦。那个醉酒的母亲拖着孩子在商店里爬行，字面上是爬行。那个父母发现她躺在自己呕吐物中的少女。
She said, my dad said, oh we should we should clean her up. And my mom said, no, let her lie in it. Maybe she'll learn something. Well I did. I learned to try to throw up before I passed out.
她说：我爸爸说，哦，我们应该给她清理一下。我妈妈说，不，让她躺在那里。也许她能学到点什么。好吧，我确实学到了。我学会在晕倒前试着把东西吐出来。
I decided that my husband should be dead. And I planned what I call today, the perfect murder. I've got to tell you that I was on Valiums at the time. That I was going to put the Valiums in the beer. I was going to have him drink it and I was going to cut him in little bitty pieces with a Black and Decker saw and throw Humpty Dumpty all over Illinois.
我决定我丈夫应该死。我策划了今天所谓的完美谋杀。我得告诉你我当时服用了安定。我本来要把安定放进啤酒里。我要让他喝下去，然后我要用一把百得（Black and Decker）锯子把他切成小块，把“矮胖子”（Humpty Dumpty）撒遍伊利诺伊州。
I'm looking at a photograph of the producer of that program. His name is Jim Nayder. It's in People magazine. He's mugging for the camera.
我看着那档节目的制作人照片。他叫吉姆·奈德（Jim Nayder）。他在《人物》杂志上。他正在对着镜头搞怪。
I have cotton in my ears and I'm just sort of making a face that, sort of nauseous look.
我耳朵里塞着棉花，我只是在做一个表情，那种有点恶心的样子。
And was it their idea to put cotton in your ears?
那是他们出的主意把棉花塞进你耳朵里吗？
It was my idea for the cotton, but not the nauseous look.
棉花是我出的主意，但那种恶心的表情不是。
Jim Nader is the Dr. Jeckyl and Mr. Wacky of public radio. He divides his time between documenting the horror stories of addicts and spinning grand pop mistakes on his nationally syndicated three-minute-long Annoying Music Show. I heard about this show before I actually heard it. And the idea sounds awful, disingenuous. What's easier than taking potshots at the musical oeuvre of the Brady Bunch?
吉姆·奈德是公共广播界的“杰基尔医生与古怪先生”。他将时间分配在记录成瘾者恐怖故事和在全国联合播出的、三分钟长的《恼人音乐秀》（The Annoying Music Show）中翻炒流行音乐的错误。我在听到这个节目之前就听说过它。这个想法听起来很糟糕，虚伪。还有什么比嘲笑《布雷迪家族》的音乐作品更容易的呢？
Then I actually listened to it. It turns out that Nayder's work is not the nadir of civilization I anticipated. The show is actually pleasurable and real, partly because of Nayder's deadpan announcing. He's not a wacky guy spinning another wacky disk. He does the show straight, as if he were a classical music announcer riffing on the significance of the post neo whatchamacallit.
然后我真的去听了。结果奈德的作品并不是我预期的文明底线。这个节目其实既令人愉悦又真实，部分是因为奈德那扑克脸的播音。他不是那种播放古怪唱片的古怪家伙。他一本正经地做节目，好像他是一位正在谈论后新某种什么什么主义重要性的古典音乐播音员。
Hi, I'm Jim Nayder and welcome to The Annoying Music Show . Often the very best annoying music is produced went two great forms of music are combined, creating music so annoying it's almost dangerous. Today we have the perfect annoying example. It's a mix of bluegrass and soul performed by the Burns Brothers.
嗨，我是吉姆·奈德，欢迎收看《恼人音乐秀》。通常最棒的恼人音乐是在两种伟大的音乐形式结合时产生的，创造出几乎危险的恼人音乐。今天我们有一个完美的恼人例子。这是伯恩斯兄弟（Burns Brothers）表演的蓝草音乐与灵魂乐的混合体。
Most of my passion, I think, goes into Magnificent Obsession . The experience of Magnificent Obsession in a week to me is much more moving on a bunch of levels. Number one, someone will make contact with me to be on the show. I'll go to their office or their kitchen or they'll come to my little studio, and in the course of a couple of hours they'll have sit there and told me their deepest, darkest, funniest, most uplifting experience. And I've never met this person before.
我想，我的大部分激情都投入到了《宏大痴迷》中。对我来说，一周内《宏大痴迷》的经历在很多层面上都更动人。第一，有人会联系我上节目。我会去他们的办公室或厨房，或者他们来到我的小工作室，在几小时内，他们坐在那里告诉我他们内心深处最黑暗、最有趣、最令人振奋的经历。而我以前从没见过这个人。
I think that's why that's more my passion. It feels more important work.
我想这就是为什么那更是我的热情所在。感觉这是更重要的工作。
Guess which show's more popular. The emotionally gruesome alcoholic adventure or Mae West singing "When a Man Loves a Woman?" Magnificent Obsession airs on 47 stations. The Annoying Music Show is on 123. On WBEZ, Nayder's home station, The Annoying Music Show is heard on Saturday afternoons by loads of listeners. Magnificent Obsession is on at 4:30 in the morning. Even Nayder sleeps through it.
猜猜哪个节目更受欢迎？情感上毛骨悚然的酗酒冒险，还是梅·韦斯特（Mae West）演唱的《当男人爱上女人》？《宏大痴迷》在47个电台播出。《恼人音乐秀》在123个电台播出。在奈德的大本营WBEZ电台，《恼人音乐秀》在周六下午被大批听众收听。《宏大痴迷》则在凌晨4:30播出。连奈德自己都睡过去了。
You might think that Nayder would be, well, annoyed by The Annoying Show's Darwinian lead considering that he says magnificent obsession is his true passion. But no matter how many times you ask him how he feels about that, his answer is that it makes sense. Which is so mature. He understands that that's the way the world works.
你可能认为奈德会因为《恼人音乐秀》那达尔文主义式的领先地位而感到恼火，考虑到他说《宏大痴迷》才是他真正的热情所在。但无论你问多少次他对此有何感受，他的回答是“这说得通”。这太成熟了。他明白这就是世界运作的方式。
Yeah. I don't want to over analyze it. I think people just need a good laugh. You know? I think people are desperate for a good laugh.
是的。我不想过度分析它。我想人们只是需要大笑一场。你知道吗？我认为人们非常渴望一场大笑。
So both shows actually are kind of a response to human pain in a way, if you describe it that way.
所以这两个节目其实都以某种方式是对人类痛苦的回应，如果你那样描述的话。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
Maybe this is way too obvious, but I was thinking about where your two worlds collide. The annoying music and drugs. And I was thinking, of course, it is William Shatner's "Lucy in the Sky With Diamonds." You know, you've got LSD, you've got this Beatles' butchering. I mean, it's like one of those things where, you know, some people remember where they were when Kennedy was shot. I remember where I was when I heard that song the first time. I was like, you know, my world turned around. And, you know, I prefer it to the Beatles now. I mean, it is like the most joyous, most humbling, most magnificent piece of music I could imagine and I can't even imagine doing it.
也许这太显而易见了，但我一直在想你的两个世界在哪里碰撞。恼人音乐和毒品。我一直在想，当然，那就是威廉·夏特纳（William Shatner）唱的《露西在缀满钻石的天空》（Lucy in the Sky With Diamonds）。你知道，你有LSD，你有这首披头士作品的被屠杀版。我的意思是，这就好比，有些人记得肯尼迪遇刺时他们在哪里。我记得第一次听到那首歌时我在哪里。我觉得，你知道，我的世界天翻地覆。而且，你知道，我现在比喜欢披头士更喜欢它。我的意思是，它就像我能想象到的最欢乐、最令人谦卑、最宏大的音乐片段，我甚至无法想象它是怎么做出来的。
And it's a complete mystery to me why that is. Like, why do you think that song is so powerful? And people agree. Someone told me that when William Shatner was on Conan O'Brien the other week, that they played "Lucy in the Sky With Diamonds" when he came out. So it's like, oh, it's not just me.
为什么会这样对我来说是一个完全的谜。就像，你为什么觉得那首歌那么有感染力？人们也同意。有人告诉我，威廉·夏特纳前几周上柯南·奥布莱恩（Conan O'Brien）节目时，他出场时他们放的就是《露西在缀满钻石的天空》。所以这就像，哦，不只是我。
I think a lot of that is the power of Captain Kirk, William Shatner.
我想很大程度上是柯克船长（Captain Kirk）、威廉·夏特纳的力量。
Or even when he does, when Shatner does "Mr. Tambourine Man." You know how it goes out, where he's screaming, "Mr. Tambourine Man." And it's like, you know, Marlon Brando yelling "Stella."
或者甚至当他唱，当夏特纳唱《铃鼓先生》（Mr. Tambourine Man）的时候。你知道它是怎么结束的，他尖叫着“铃鼓先生”。这感觉就像，你知道，马龙·白兰度（Marlon Brando）在那儿大喊“斯特拉！”（Stella）。
Which brings us to the fundamental problem of wackiness. Is it OK to like it? What if it can't be helped?
这把我们带回了古怪的基本问题。喜欢它没问题吗？如果无法抗拒怎么办？
Sometimes when I listen to The Annoying Music Show , a show that I really love and yet I find myself questioning that love. And I feel like the part of me that loves it is sort of dead inside. Like, there's something--
有时当我听《恼人音乐秀》时，一个我真正喜爱的节目，但我发现自己质疑那种喜爱。我感觉我内心热爱它的那一部分已经死了。就像，有什么东西——
Cynical, you're cynical?
愤世嫉俗，你很愤世嫉俗吗？
Is that it? Is it, like, the guilt of irony? Do you see it as an ironic show?
是那样吗？是那种讽刺的内疚吗？你把它看作一个讽刺性的节目吗？
Yeah. And and it pains me sometimes to think that there are artists that I really like that the only chance I'll get to play their music is to highlight an annoying song. I just sort of grew up buying 78s and old records and I love Kate Smith and Bing Crosby and all those people. And there's-- Kate Smith singing "The Ballad of the Green Beret" is an instant hit on The Annoying Music Show . And that's the only chance I'll get to play Kate Smith on there. So there is a twinge of I'm really knocking this artist in some way.
是的。有时想到有些我真正喜爱的艺术家，而我唯一能播放他们音乐的机会竟然是为了突出那首歌有多恼人，这让我感到痛苦。我从小就是听78转唱片和旧唱片长大的，我喜欢凯特·史密斯（Kate Smith）、平·克劳斯贝（Bing Crosby）和那些人。凯特·史密斯唱的《绿色贝雷帽之歌》在《恼人音乐秀》里立马火了。而那竟然是我在那里播放凯特·史密斯的唯一机会。所以确实有一种刺痛感，觉得我以某种方式在贬低这位艺术家。
The problem with doing a supposedly wacky show, or a deadly serious one, is that all the other parts of your personality never get expressed. Nayder's two shows must require a fairly schizophrenic to do list. Like one minute he's looking for the best possible worst version of Rod Stewart's "Do You Think i'm Sexy?" and the next minute he's editing the cautionary tale of a drunk who lived in alleys.
做一个所谓的“古怪”节目，或者一个极度严肃的节目的问题在于，你个性的所有其他部分永远得不到表达。奈德的两个节目一定需要一份相当精神分裂的工作清单。就像这一分钟他还在寻找罗德·斯图尔特（Rod Stewart）《你觉得我性感吗？》最糟糕的版本，下一分钟他就在编辑一个住在小巷里的酒鬼的警世故事。
But if his psyche has dual citizenship his pocketbook has pledged allegiance to the wacky flag. The Annoying Music Show is his moneymaker.
但如果他的灵魂拥有双重国籍，他的钱包却已经向古怪旗帜宣誓效忠。《恼人音乐秀》是他的赚钱工具。
Prostitution. Income and getting my daughter through college. Go ahead and laugh, but in two years The Annoying Music Show will gross enough that Nayder won't need another source of income. There will be CDs, there will be paraphernalia. Yes, this paraphernalia will be wacky. His daughter's college tuition will be paid for through the sale of hats equipped with ear plugs, and barf bags.
卖淫。收入，让我的女儿读完大学。去笑吧，但在两年内，《恼人音乐秀》的毛利将足够让奈德不需要其他收入来源。会有CD，会有周边产品。是的，这些周边产品会是很古怪的。他女儿的大学学费将通过出售配备耳塞和呕吐袋的帽子来支付。
It is a tribute to the power of wackiness that with millions of people in recovery programs all over this great nation, Nayder won't be financing his daughter's education with profits from Magnificent Obsession coffee thermoses or souvenir nicotine patches. Wacky sells.
这就是古怪力量的明证，在这个伟大的国家有数百万人在康复计划中，而奈德不会用《宏大痴迷》咖啡保温杯或纪念性尼古丁贴片的利润来资助女儿的教育。古怪好卖。
And we at This American Life are not above cashing in. Pledge drive's coming up, so let's take it out with a song. Maestro.
我们《这就是美国生活》也不会错过赚钱的机会。捐款季快到了，让我们用一首歌来收尾吧。大师。
Sarah Vowell is the author of Radio On and a columnist for Salon magazine online.
莎拉·沃威尔是《Radio On》一书的作者，也是Salon在线杂志的专栏作家。
Wacky and warm is part of my package too.
古怪和热情也是我包装的一部分。
Indeed it is. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life .
确实如此。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。